let people who are non-islamic who are
fleeing those areas at the front of the
queue first but isn't that isn't that
religious persecution I mean or at the
very least it's prejudiced right I mean
you're you're you're singling people out
because of their ideology or because of
what religion they're from not because
of their past behavior or any predictors
whatsoever about their future behavior
but we do have some statistical
regularity about what types of values
those guys are going to come with so I'm
not suggesting we close the door right
wouldn't that cut in a way I mean just
to play devil's out you wouldn't that in
a way kind of put the Muslims in Toronto
who do immigrant which would have picked
that City who tried to immigrate to
Canada in the same sort of a position
that your family was in in Lebanon where
you were hiding the fact that you were
Jews
no one has an inalienable syllable that
constitutes a belief attitude position
value that is contrary to ours at the
door and then welcomed in my brother but
man isn't that a crazy thing to say to
someone whose entire life and their
ideology is a big part of their identity
and who they are like how they view the
world so that's the structure for which
they interface with other human beings
but if those values so let's suppose
they were with you know in a way I agree
with you overall when I talk about the
entire human population then it would be
wonderful if we did that but from
individual to individual we know about
the trials and tribulations that people
go through in a day to day life and
religious freedom and a religious
ideology in many cases helps people get
through the pains of life it helps them
get through the struggles so now what
you have here I would say this guy is an
anti constitutional issue for a because
in our Constitution yeah you have what
freedom of religion so can we say that
this guy is saying basically you you can
come to America but leave your Islamic
yeah that's exactly what he's what do
you say about this well I think that
that's
online I'm also saying this guy is this
but this that's more aligned with a
fascist belief rather than a liberal
belief thank you
because fascism comes from the the word
fascio which literally means to bundle
everyone up together and to rule over
them with the same ideology so in other
words a uniformity and the way everyone
what everyone believes is required in
fascism people like Carl Schmitt talked
about this one of the fascist
philosopher and Nazi philosophers so
what he's saying is more in line with
with that one then is in line with
liberalism to be fair to Joe though he
did actually disagree with the sentiment
which is which is good or good was cut
good was coming out Joe was standing up
I mean for some some of the American
principles right right he was saying I
was trying to play devil's advocate but
I think his good sight that was coming
out I think he's reluctant disagree with
his guests Yeah right he's reluctant to
disagree with him but he was he's
playing this devil's advocate why he was
at he was saying I disagree I agree with
parts of it which implied he disagreed
with parts of what this ban was saying
sometimes you got to change your friends
brother if you want to grow you just
can't be around the same people they're
gonna bring you down it's true it was
this guy spreading hate man yes true be
saying basically do you know what the
significance of what he's saying is that
people who are fleeing persecution
because that's what's happening there
they're fleeing person Muslims who are
fleeing persecution they are dying women
and children who are coming what if this
man had his way because he was talking
about how Muslims would have it their
way this man had a his way we'd have to
apostate from our religion in order to
enter into a safe zone yeah sounds very
constitutionalist okay or of
pro-constitution i don't think so i
think is this man is very as you've said
correctly anti-constitution yeah let's
go to the next one yes
you